in this age of social media an instant
streaming everything is being watched
and discussed by someone when a new
season rolls around and you look at the
inordinate number of new shows even when
scrolling down to see some obscure
concepts like sin Rousseau Joe where the
entire premise is just kinda hanna's our
making cute anime noises it'll still
have a dedicated following who are
discussing it and if a show is awesome
enough more likely than not it'll bubble
up to the surface so that even if you
don't end up watching it you're likely
to have at least heard of it but one
thing I do miss about the age before is
that feeling of discovering a hidden gem
I remember one day I was browsing some
random anime forum you know back when
people still used anime forums and some
user had this signature of an anime I'd
never heard of with a name I couldn't
even pronounce Gann could sue God could
sow cook GaN could sue oh the kind of
Monte Cristo I've heard of that however
something about it stood out to me the
art style was really unique and the
counter looked like a badass so just
from that one image alone I decided to
give it a watch it was something I gave
a chance in a complete whim and yet
somehow I had discovered some of the
best writing this medium had to offer
and what is still the best revenge anime
I have seen to this day it was a hidden
gem even back then hardly anyone was
talking about it and now pretty much
everyone has forgotten it so today I
wanted to talk about an irrelevant show
no one is talking about in a time no one
is watching it gunkid sir The Count of
Monte Cristo is an anime adaptation to
the classic story by Alexandre Dumas The
Count of Monte Cristo it's based on his
thing called a heavy light novel also
known as a novel the original story was
written and set in the 1800s which might
be a bit confusing considering this
adaptation is set in 5050 3-space France
but aside from the odd thing like people
still using paper letters are not
communicating by phones it actually
works because at its core it's a story
that can be appreciated in any time
period this is a tale of revenge one
that blends in corruption deception love
aristocracy naivety trust and more now
when i say revenge i don't mean a simple
straightforward kind of revenge plot
like
not that there's anything wrong with
that but the brilliance of the plot
comes from the complex way the revenge
scheme is set up and unfolds bringing
together the abundance of Port threads
conspiracies and character motivations
without ever feeling like any element
was tacked on or underdeveloped you
watch as this entity known only as the
count slowly weaves its way into the
lives of a varied colorful cast of
characters unbeknownst to them but a
storm of vengeance is about to envelop
everyone as the count's leaves a trail
of retribution to anyone who has wronged
in before you know how an anime they
play off these characters doing these
super-smart schemes we're like these
11-year olds are playing five D
intergalactic chess with each other
unveiling this epic plan using details
viewers would never be able to know like
aha you fell for my trap you fool that
was just part of my plan
I just wanted you to think I fell for
your trap I've been planning this before
you even set your trap ha I actually
just wanted you to think that I thought
that I fell for your trap I've been
planning this since I was a child ha ha
ha well guess what [ __ ] I wanted you
to think that I thought that you thought
that I thought that you fell for my trap
I've been planning this before I was
even born and you're just sitting there
like mahan when I was 11 I couldn't even
calculate 8 times 7 without help from my
calculator in gonca soooo every detail
of the scheme is laid out for you as it
happens there is no big just according
to K Kaku reveal you are shown all the
preparation with or without context
things happen that don't make sense
until 8 episodes later the entire series
is one big plan and you get to see it
all unfold piece by piece until you
realize that from the very moment you
met him every meticulous aspect had
already been planned out by the counter
to the most minut of details and because
of this I would never be able to fully
sell to you the true brilliance of this
show with how every detail is so
intricately woven in together and that
is a [ __ ] accomplishment when you
realize just how many characters are
juggles the cast is absolutely massive
with enough characters and relationships
to keep track of that even a graph
wouldn't make this easy oh god what the
[ __ ] is this yet somehow everyone feels
like they bring something and even the
minor characters have a chance to shine
even if individually some characters may
come off as annoying or frustrating the
ad
the overall dynamic and themes of the
plots but of course the person that
brings it all together is the count
himself to me the count remains one of
the most spellbinding characters I've
seen in anime an entity that oozes
charisma commanding an on-screen
presence that demands your attention
there's just something mesmerizing about
watching him work he's ruthless charming
mysterious and incredibly complex driven
to a point of obsession allowing nothing
to get in the way to his path of
vengeance and yet no matter how many
people he manipulates or innocent
bystanders he uses and gets caught in
his crossfire you can't help but cheer
for him even though we see the story for
the eyes of a young boy named our bear
his presence is always felt like a
puppeteer controlling the strings from
the shadows orchestrating the most
intricate of plays but having said that
it does take a bit of time before that
play is set in motion the modern anime
climate has conditioned us to pay
attention to shows that are fast and
hard-hitting so when I say the first
eight or so episodes can seem a little
slow I can already feel some of you
mentally bringing down this title 50 or
so places down in your watch list but
trust me when I say that it's worth the
payoff the beginning episodes are
definitely slower but necessary to
introduce you to the world characters
and most importantly you see the count
setting up the dominoes putting
everything in place
piece by piece until the structure is a
10 stack ultimate Jenga world record
Domino rally and he just goes every
characters are porn in this giant chess
game every plot points a piece for the
bigger puzzle after a while the show
just reaches this point where the
dominoes start falling action after
action leads to frenzied reaction
everyone's lives is one-by-one turned
upside down it's chaos it's anarchy and
through the turmoil you watch as the
count plays conductor to this chaotic
Orchestra as everyone dances along to
the beat of his mesmerizing symphony
it's incredibly rewarding it's one of
those shows where you're suddenly on a
10-episode binge and you look at the
clock and you're like [ __ ] is 4 a.m.
already ah crap I've got work at 7:00
ah well 2 hours of sleep is probably
enough for basic bodily functions of
course it's not perfect the last half of
the penultimate episode Rob's it from a
perfect conclusion the cg makes today's
worst attempt look like a photo
realistic prototype render running on
the Unreal 10 engine and as you can see
the unique art style is either a lover
hater kind of thing as it looks like
someone had a wicked night out drop some
LSD and passed out in a carpet store
however I don't think that's enough to
take away from the brilliance of the
anime that can still be enjoyed by
today's standards I called this my
hidden gem but as coincidental as the
situation I discovered it was its
ironically probably more likely than
someone randomly stumbling on it today
though I mean is still available in
control and Funimation for North America
so even if only new shows are promoted
on there people might have still
discovered it by browsing through titles
alphabetically yeah it's possible almost
there it's rare you come across the
series that manages to drag or multitude
of plot points characters themes and
motivations weaving it all together in a
satisfying way that makes it work to the
point where you finish it and you can't
help but marvel either thought how are
the hell did the writer plan all this
recently I talked about classics and
timeless stories and I don't think
there's a more telling indicator that a
story has survived the passage of time
when it's almost 200 years old this
might not have gone down as an anime
classic that the community has
remembered but it is still one of my
personal favorites and a show I won't
ever stop recommending
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]